hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast recent progress in
predictive biomarker testing in
non-small-cell lung cancer presented by
dr. john w longshore PhD fac mg we are
excited to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by roche diagnostics as a
global leader in health care roche
diagnostics offers a broad portfolio of
tools that help healthcare providers in
the early detection prevention diagnosis
and treatment of diseases in molecular
diagnostics Roche Diagnostics is driven
by a vision of working with laboratories
like yours to improve the medical value
you offer in virology women's health
microbiology genomics and oncology the
company continues to meet unmet needs
through its investment in research
innovation and scientific excellence
with the goal of supporting your
important role in improving patients
lives to learn more visit us Diagnostics
Roche calm
I'm Karen benzene genomics and oncology
marketing manager for roche diagnostics
i'll be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like everyone to
be aware that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you like
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation this is an educational
webinar and thus offers siiii credits
after the webinar has concluded please
click on the c/e button located in the
bottom of left hand corner of your web
page and follow the process to obtain
your credits also please note that you
will be viewing the presentation in the
slide window to enlarge the window click
on the screen icon located in the lower
right finally if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the support button located at the top
right of the presentation window or use
the Q&A button to let us know that
you're having a problem thank you for
your attention and now I'd like to
introduce today's speaker dr. John W log
shore after completing his undergraduate
work in Applied biology at Georgia Tech
John received his PhD in medical
genetics from the University of Alabama
at Birmingham and completed a fellowship
in clinical molecular genetics at the
Greenwood genetics center since 2001 he
has worked with the Carolinas pathology
group as director of molecular pathology
for the Carolinas laboratory network his
primary responsibility is supervision of
the molecular pathology laboratory which
provides state-of-the-art molecular
testing services for the hospitals and
facilities within the carolinas
healthcare system dr. longshore is a
diplomate of the american board of
medical genetics in clinical molecular
genetics and an active member of the
American College of medical genetics the
American Society of Human Genetics and
the Association for molecular pathology
away from his profile
life John and Joy's fly fishing swimming
travel and spending time with his wife
and children please joining me in
welcoming dr. longshore I will now turn
the presentation over to him good
morning thank you very much Karen for
that kind introduction thank you to lab
roots for the invitation to present in
the session today into roche diagnostics
for their support of this program
biomarker based therapy and oncology has
become the standard of care over the
last decade and it's certainly an
exciting time in the field of
personalized medicine and companion
diagnostics although I work for
Carolina's pathology group my primary
professional responsibility is directing
the molecular pathology lab for the
carolinas HealthCare System wizard which
is a large integrated health network
built a based in Charlotte North
Carolina it's a 43 hospital system that
has large academic tertiary care centers
as well as small community hospitals and
about 62,000 employees at 900 care
locations therefore we have an extremely
diverse set of position needs for
biomarker testing both in the community
setting and the academic type setting
but the primary enterprise for carolinas
healthcare system is in metro charlotte
north carolina my lab is a full-service
molecular pathology lab providing assays
and all molecular specialties we also
have a very robust clinical trial
central pathology operation and
extensive experience with multiple
companion diagnostic or personalized
medicine platforms we offer all
available companion diagnostic targets
in my laboratories both with DNA fish or
fluorescent in situ hybridization and
immunohistochemistry based testing in
addition to that we have next-generation
sequencing available for expanding
screening when that is indicated for
patient care so let's move on to talking
about lung cancer because it really is a
significant global health issue we spend
a lot of time in the United States in
October talking about breast cancer and
women's health where we think of all the
fall the pink that we see and in
November prostate cancer or men's health
but in addition to those two very worthy
cause
as lung cancer is a far more common
cause of death in the United States we
see about 1.8 million you cases per year
so within the carolinas HealthCare
System and the Levine Cancer Institute
that means we have over 3,000 new cases
of lung cancer that we see on an annual
basis so why is lung cancer so fatal
this really lies relies upon the fact
that lung cancer is usually diagnosed in
an advanced stage which means that over
fifty percent of patients with lung
cancer are diagnosed at Stage four or
advanced metastatic cancer we have a
limited but a growing number of targeted
therapeutics but overall still a fairly
poor five-year survival rate even with
these dramatic advances in therapy that
have been made over the past few years
so let's begin our presentation today
talking about a few core concepts that I
think will aid us as we get into the
presentation what is a biomarker in its
most basic form a biomarker is a
biological event that is associated with
an abnormal cellular behavior this can
be a genetic alteration that can be
detected with a molecular or DNA based
test or it can be a protein expression
or chromosomal translocation that can be
detected with immunohistochemistry or
fish or fluorescent in situ
hybridization now moving forward into
companion diagnostics a companion
diagnostic really has a dual purpose it
is first and foremost the detection of a
biomarker and then secondly utilization
of the biomarker information in patient
care either in selecting patients
therapeutics determining the duration
and dosage of therapeutics and also
helping to reduce adverse outcomes the
FDA did a very nice job of summarizing
what a companion diagnostic is that you
can see the bottom of the slide an IBD
companion diagnostic device is an in
vitro diagnostic device that provides
information that is essential for the
safe and effective use of a
corresponding therapeutic product we
have something new that is called a
complementary diagnostic that has been
approved by the FDA within the past few
months a companion diagnostic is
relatively easy to understand a
complementary diagnostic much less so a
complementary
diagnostic is a test that provides
additional information about how a drug
might be used whether someone might
respond to a class of drugs but is not
required for the safe and effective use
of the drug and at present we only have
one complimentary diagnostic that is
approved in the US market and this is
nivolumab or up Deebo from bristol-myers
squibb it is associated with the doc Oh
28-8 farm DX immunohistochemistry test
and so there is no label for the testing
within the drug prescribing information
so this really leads us to BC with
complementary Diagnostics will testing
be ordered and only time will tell if it
is truly a competitive advantage for a
therapeutic to have a label as a
complementary diagnostic versus a
companion diagnostic so we do have lots
of challenges with implementing
companion diagnostic testing in the US
so I think it's important to remember
these we have difficulty conserving
sufficient tissue and pathology
collecting sufficient tissue during the
biopsy process we have multiple methods
that can be used for personalized
medicine testing with each having a
different sensitivity specificity and
this kind of flies in the face of the
the gold standard of companion
diagnostics which is standardization of
the testing process we struggle with
reimbursement for newer biomarker test
patients see usually a wide delay
between their presentation with clinical
symptoms and the results of their
biomarker testing being returned to them
we have limited clinical information for
non driver mutations which is really a
challenge with next-generation
sequencing panels we have still many
institutions that do not have or heavily
utilize multidisciplinary tumor boards
particularly systems that are
geographically isolated clinics and
specialty so I have some solutions that
may be helpful with that and then it's
also very importantly challenging to
stay current in a rapidly evolving
oncology setting challenging to maintain
up-to-date laboratory report information
stay current with clinical testing
guidelines and also stay current with
available clinical trial enrollment
opportunities for oncology patients
so let's talk a little bit about the
lung cancer patient journey it is quite
complex and involves many many steps I
have counted as many as a total of
twenty processes or steps that a patient
would be involved in in diagnosis they
will have their clinical presentation
then imaging and radiology a biopsy
that's perform testing that's performed
and then results communicated back to
them as far as the physician specialties
that would be involved they would likely
present with their initial symptoms to
primary care then be referred to a
radiologist for imaging then to an
oncologist then either to a radiologist
or pulmonologist for a biopsy collection
and then to the laboratory medicine or
pathology both for diagnosis
histological diagnosis and any needed
biomarker testing so a question today is
how do we help to expedite in this
process given its many cumbersome steps
and multiple medical specialties that
are involved in patient care so how
important our companion diagnostics in
oncology today for reference let's
review the nccn non-small cell lung
cancer guidelines and these are the most
up-to-date guidelines as you can see
after a histological diagnosis is
established companion diagnostic tests
alone drive treatment decisions and for
non-small cell lung cancer these tests
are EGFR and alch at this time in
addition the NCCN recommends expanded
screening for non-small cell lung cancer
to determine eligibility for future
therapeutics such as in b-raf met Ross 1
which is now approved for crizotinib
therapy her to and repped so this is why
we are here this morning if we look at
the biomarker testing journey how do we
go from a symptomatic patient to the
best treatment decision as rapidly as
possible because time is precious and we
want to get as many patients as possible
enrolled in targeted therapeutics or
clinical trial opportunities that they
have but as we mentioned earlier there
are many many steps and many specialties
involved in this process
this is a current current list of
approved companion diagnostics in
oncology the oldest test that you will
see on here or the grandfather of
companion diagnostics would be for her
to new and tries to the map which has
been on the market for almost a decade
the newest approvals in the companion
diagnostic world would be for egfr and
to grisso or awesome arab that was
approved in november of 2015 and also
for the PDL one inhibitor Prindle ism ab
orkut rooted that was approved in late
2015 as well all of these tests have
three associated techniques
immunohistochemistry is used for
companion diagnostic testing in her to
alch and PDL one fish or fluorescent in
situ hybridization is used for her to
and alch and pcr-based testing easily
real-time pcr is used for the balance of
test for companion diagnostics and
oncology so let's move into EGFR because
today we're going to spend quite a bit
of time discussing EGFR out in PDL one
in greater detail with egfr or the
epidermal growth factor receptor and
there are at this present time in the US
for approved therapeutic agents on the
market and to approved companion
diagnostic tests the Roche kobus EGFR
test and the cottage and thier screen
test therapy is indicated for patients
with exon 19 deletions or exon 21
substitution mutations as detected by an
fda-approved test mert nib is directed
at t790m positive patients that can be
detected with the Roche EGFR aversion to
test within the egfr gene there are a
wide variety of mutations that are
illustrated in this graphic exon 19
deletions in exon 21 substitutions
comprise approximately ninety percent of
all mutations that you see in patients
that are positive for an EGFR mutation
and these patients would be eligible for
biomarker driven therapy with in exon 20
the t790m mutation is the primary
resistance mutation that you see in
these patients there are others such as
mutations in exon 18 that show increased
sensitivity to
Arsene kinase inhibitors but at present
have no drug label claim one of the real
challenges that we have working with
lung cancer is it's the smallest
biopsies usually a core needle biopsy or
a fine needle aspirate and the largest
number of tests that we have to perform
so it can be very challenging to have
sufficient clinical material available
to perform all needed diagnostic testing
after treatment with targeted therapy or
the primary EGFR drugs resistant begins
to develop for patients with exon 19
deletions in L 858 are mutations we now
know that approximately two-thirds of
these patients develop resistance
through the t790m mutation and right now
we have one approved therapeutic from
astrazeneca on market in the u.s. that
targets the t790m mutation within EGFR
after a durable response however many of
these patients go on to develop tertiary
resistance due to either met
amplification or histological squamous
cell conversion or other processes so it
seems that this is a never-ending
process to chase resistant mechanisms
for the EGFR mutations something you
hear quite a bit about today is the
sensitivity for the t790m mutation it's
typically a much more challenging
mutation to detect than an excellent
exon 19 deletion or an exon 21
substitution mutation and at present
only one test in the US the Roche Kobus
test has a claim to detect the EGFR
t790m mutation the mutation sensitivity
varies quite widely between currently
available tests that can be performed to
detect this mutation ranging anywhere
from two point two to five percent up to
seventeen and a half percent for tests
available on the market where it is in
the level of two to three percent for
other EGFR mutations based upon work
that's been performed in my lab and
others we also know that the sensitivity
of the t790m mutation is much more
challenging to detect with
next-generation sequencing than it is
with a real-time PCR assay so my advice
would be to choose your testing platform
wisely and quite carefully for the best
sensitivity for the t790m
mutation it's also interesting that many
responders to therapy and t790m negative
patients that you will read about in
clinical trials are likely due to test
sensitivity issues so please choose your
testing platform wisely 47 9am mutations
moving into a land a plastic lymphoma
receptor kinase or the out mutation
there's a translocation commonly
associated between alcon the EML for
which is the dominant fusion partner
where there are several others such as
KLC one kif 5b and TFG that are
translocation partners of alch this drug
crizotinib that is associated for
positive patients has been approved in
the US market since august of 2011 and
we see out mutations in somewhere
between three to five percent of
non-small cell lung cancer patients
initially approved approval the abbot
vices out break apart fish probe was the
associated companion diagnostic test but
in 2015 the the Ventana d5 f3
immunohistochemistry test was
retrospectively validated as a companion
diagnostic so therapy is indicated for
out positive non-small cell lung cancer
patients as detected by one of these two
FDA approved methods we also have to
Kwazii companion diagnostics i will call
Cerreta nib and elective that are
available in the market for patients who
are either intolerant tickers at nib or
who have progressed on crisanta therapy
so although they do not have an
associated companion diagnostic test
they are only indicated for patients who
have responded who have progressed on
Crisanta therapy so therefore these
patients will have had companion
diagnostic testing prior to using one of
these two therapeutic agents so I
mentioned on my last slide alch also had
a second companion diagnostic that is
immunohistochemistry based approved in
jun 2015 the Ventana d5 f3 sa was
cleared for use with crizotinib as a
companion diagnostic and it shows some
advantages that were fished that it has
a binary scoring algorithm looking for
granular assad applies an extending of
tumor cells with the fluorescent in situ
fishbase test we look for greater than
fifteen percent of cells showing the
translocation to be considered positive
for the fish result however with
immunohistochemistry any percent
positive tumor cells are considered is
considered a positive result and
patients would be eligible for
crizotinib so there are some competitive
advantages for IHC versus fish for
looking for the out translocation it's
more rapid less expensive much more
widely available in histology labs and
requires much many fewer tumor cells for
analysis as I will show you on the next
slide and also there are some ongoing
studies that show crizotinib response in
some patients who are negative for the
fish out test but positive for the IHC
test availability of this I HC testing
should expand access to the therapeutic
if we look at these advantages and
disadvantages of out versus fish I think
you can see that the
immunohistochemistry assay can be much
more easily automated it uses
conventional microscopy versus
fluorescent microscopy it has a quicker
turnaround time a binary scoring
algorithm is less expensive and is
available in many more histology labs
versus solder genetics or anatomic
pathology labs for the fish testing it
also seems to have a higher catch rate
for crizotinib therapy so it will be
interesting to see the the traction the
IHC test gains in the market over the
next year this case is a really nice
example of the power of
immunohistochemistry and looking at
small tumor samples as i said we use
binary scoring for immunohistochemistry
so any cluster of staining cells is
considered a positive result if you
contrast this with fish you need at
least 50 cells to be evaluated to be
able to have statistical significance to
find a positive result for out testing
so the availability of IHC testing such
as for the patient illustrated in this
slide or the tissue illustrated in the
slide gives a patient access to a
therapeutic who would otherwise not be
eligible to receive targeted therapy
one of the joys of oncology testing is
working with formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues they have a
variable tumor content we have tumor
heterogeneity within these tissues any
variable mutation spectrum they are
mixtures of normal and tumor tissue and
within the tumor tissue some cells will
contain the mutations you are looking
for others will not formula damaged
yields a small amount of amplified will
DNA due to breaking the DNA backbone and
we also have to deal with necrosis and
melanin and sometimes decalcified
tissues when we work with formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissue so proper
sample prep is essential for getting a
high-quality biomarker testing result
after tissue collection we fix the
sample we cut unstained slides and we
perform an HD stain to determine the
tumor content which Guild's a blue or
purple color to the tumor and the
nuclear features of the cells usually
for our biomarker testing for egfr alch
and ross we will use for unstained
slides and obtain one H&E staining side
that we use to determine tumor content
and these are cut at a 5 micron
thickness this is a great example of a
tissue that came in recently that has
quite a large amount of tissue you can
see two large tissue cores and one small
core in the middle but the problem is
there is only two percent tumor content
so we hear a lot of talk these days
about making sure we have sufficient
tissue available for biomarker testing
and really what we need to be talking
about is making sure we have sufficient
tumor content available for all needed
biomarker testing but however in this
case with the testing methodologies that
are used in my lab we were able to
detect an exon 19 deletion and an EGFR
t790m mutation off of a single slide
even with this low amount of tumor
content in this sample as a second
example here are three samples that
arrived recently in my lab in a single
day just wide variety of samples that
come in the first one in the upper left
hand of your screen you can see he has
about seventy percent tumor content very
small tissue of a primary lung cancer
but has a high degree
tumor content below it is a sample that
also has a very small amount of tissue
of primary lung cancer and approximately
three percent tumor just one small
island of tumor is available in the
sample contrast this with the sample on
the right which is a large lymph node
has massive amounts of tissue and tumor
available for testing and this is from a
metastatic lung cancer sample so you
really never know what type of samples
are going to come into your lab on a
daily basis for biomarker testing in the
lung cancer world it is truly a wide
variety of samples and sample types that
you do see tumor heterogeneity is a
large problem in any biomarker testing
environment as I mentioned on an earlier
slide you have mixtures of normal cells
and tumor cells and then within the
tumor cells you have cells that are
positive for mutations you were looking
for and cells that do not have the
mutation you were looking for and also
as we cut through the tissues in the
FFPE block with 5 micron slices the
mutations Barry as we section the biopsy
on a microtome and one exciting
development that we have that's widely
used in the European Union and is used
an experimental basis the United States
its plasma based testing which may help
address the issue of tumor heterogeneity
and tissue heterogeneity for lung cancer
I prefer and find it very easy to think
of tumor heterogeneity using the
dalmatian as a model if you think of a
Dalmatian as as a tumor so this will be
our animal model so to speak they are
born with a white coat so we'll say
white coat would be white cells we all
normal cells spots begin to develop in
Dalmatians when they're three to four
weeks old they come more numerous
throughout life and every dog is
different just like every tumor is
different so if we were using the the
coat of a Dalmatian as an example of a
lung tumor with the dark cells or dark
spots on a Dalmatian being the areas of
the tumor that had mutation and white
spots being does that they're not when
you perform a biopsy it's very difficult
to know exactly what you're getting we
can't perform a biopsy knowing that we
are going to hit tumor every time so
multiple navigational approaches and
navigational bronchoscopy are one
full techniques that help us work around
some of these problems with tumor
heterogeneity since we can use multiple
navigational approaches during the
biopsy process so why would you want to
use a companion diagnostic instead of
another lab technique for a given target
if we consider something as simple as
b-raf the v600e mutation that is a point
mutation we could use something as
simplistic as a pcr restriction enzyme
digest that has been around and
described since it's used in sickle cell
anemia in 1978 which was the first
widely used molecular diagnostic test
but if you do a rough count there at
least 11 possible diagnostic techniques
that can be used for mutation detection
of a point mutation the most common
method that's used in the US and around
the world according to our proficiency
surveys is saying your sequencing which
is also associated with the worst
outcomes because of the poor sensitivity
and oncology samples Sanger sequencing
has been illustrated in multiple studies
in the peer-reviewed literature to have
in the neighborhood of thirty to fifty
percent sensitivity for oncology
specimens and also when we talk about
DNA sequencing we really don't know what
what people are referring to anymore are
we talking about traditional
radioisotope Sanger sequencing but is
still used in many areas of the world
fluorescent capillary sequencing with
enrichment for Sanger sequencing or are
we talking about next-generation
sequencing will call sequencing is the
most commonly used mutation detection
technique worldwide and unmodified
Sanger sequencing has very poor
performance for oncology testing but
it's wonderful for blood-based genetic
testing and this largely is due to tumor
heterogeneity and the problems with
working with formalin-fixed
paraffin-embedded tissues so it can be
quite powerful with x generation
sequencing or have many pitfalls with
traditionals unmodified Sanger
sequencing europe has a strong history
of excellence in molecular diagnostics
and I why I'm showing the data on the
next two slides this is not unique to
Europe our College of American
Pathologists data in the u.s. shows
exactly the same
that we have but in a recent k rass
external eqa assessment in the ee with
59 laps participating they found a
thirty percent error rate or were unable
to generate the correct result using
ffpe slides of the sample type they were
both false positive results
false-negative results incorrect
mutations reported DNA isolation
failures and overall test failures so
wide variety of problems even in highly
sophisticated laboratories this is why
we need standardization this prior slide
I was considering dropping for my
presentation since it was several years
old but at the European cancer congress
meeting in Vienna last September I was
privileged to hear a presentation
looking at the EQ a quality schemes for
chaos and for egfr over the last few
years and the EQ a schemes are much more
rigorous than our cap surveys that we
have in the US and there's continued
difficulty reporting correct answers for
these both from 2009 to 2014 with k
wrasse you can see about seventy percent
of labs reported the correct genotype
for egfr in 2014 only 61 percent of the
laps reported to correct genotype so
even within highly sophisticated
molecular pathology labs for
personalized medicine due to tissue
heterogeneity and different
methodologies that are used there is a
very high error rate and this is why
companion diagnostics are beautiful
because they help standardized testing
processes and eliminate the
possibilities of error for biomarker
based testing as I said on my last slide
even within a highly skilled molecular
diagnostic lab opportunities for
variations abound with methods there are
at least 11 methods that can be used for
biomarker testing for pre-analytical
errors what's the sample type how is it
fixed where is the section in the FFPE
block what is the tumor content and what
is the mutation content for DNA or RNA
isolation was it manual or automated the
GD how to gpd paraffin eyes your samples
they'd use a kit did you use phone all
chloroform isolation was it column based
and did you start with scrolls or glass
mounted slides for instrumentation for
pcr did you use an ABI instrument a road
Jean a Z 480 a lightcycler 482 point oh
did you do sequencing next-generation
sequencing or a pcr digest and then
within even the professional
interpretation who actually does that
was it a technologist or was it
automated what was the experience level
the person performing the interpretation
was that the lab director and where they
appropriately certified for performing
this testing so there are many
opportunities for variations even within
highly sophisticated labs and that's why
standardized testing processes really
are helpful in personalized medicine
let's talk about the importance of test
result accuracy and how this can impact
patient care in personalized medicine if
you have an invalid result a patient
will have delayed treatment disease
progression and additional biopsy may be
required if you have a false negative
result a patient is not considered for
targeted therapy if you have a false
positive result a patient is considered
for a targeted therapeutic that may not
be beneficial in some cases can be
harmful so only with the correct
biomarker detection is a patient
considered for targeted therapy
associated with the improved clinical
outcomes and quality of life quality of
life outcomes we see with targeted
therapy so within laboratory in
molecular laboratories in particular
test accuracy is always important but it
has an extremely increased infants
emphasis in campagna diagnostic or
biomarker based testing if ever there
has been a win-win scenario in medicine
companion diagnostic testing is the
champion patients get the best treatment
physicians and providers are able to
optimize therapy and minimize adverse
events payers and reimbursement see
longer life reduced resource utilization
and policy and regulatory makers avoid
unnecessary care even third party payers
love companion diagnostics since a test
costing a few hundred dollars can help
predict efficacy for a ten thousand and
twelve thousand dollar a month targeted
therapy never his tissue conservation
been more important than today with lung
cancer we have the smallest biopsy and
many many tests that are required
strategic specimen conservation does
require multidisciplinary planning make
sure you obtain sufficient tissue in the
biopsy process and this will be four to
five FNA passes for 25 transbronchial
biopsies or two to three CT guided core
needle biopsies try to limit your IHC
markers used for histological diagnosis
to those that are absolutely necessary
and choose optimal companion diagnostic
and biomarker tests prioritize your
samples that contain the highest tumor
content for molecular testing sequence
your test appropriately or triage you're
testing appropriately and choose your
platform wisely most of the biopsy
procedures in my large hospitals are
performed navigational bronchoscopy or
ibas which gives us the ability to
perform biopsies with Cornelia biopsies
fine needle aspirates or even a forceps
biopsy we have standardized the process
down to four passes looking at multiple
sites in a single procedure we can
giving us a very high safety profile and
always gives a sufficient tissue for
molecular testing so the appropriate
type of biopsy and biomarker tissue
collection is really what drives the
personalized medicine conversation
around the world this is a great example
of how we use electromagnetic
navigational bronchoscopy in the biopsy
process this is a 54 year old patient
who had clinical progression on our
latinum therapy had one biopsy that was
a ct-guided biopsy that was
non-diagnostic a second ct-guided biopsy
had quantity non sufficient for
molecular testing and the patient had a
pneumothorax and that required placement
of a chest tube and we used navigational
bronchoscopy with ibas for the third
biopsy and you can see with the pink
arrow in the diagram we were able to
biopsy level 7 lymph node way 6 10
millimeter diameter lesion and so it is
a wonderful technique for our
pulmonologist to get to use that and
looking at this you can see the catheter
tip and the images and the green dot is
the target lesion that they are
approaching with navigational
bronchoscopy
one of the nice things of
multidisciplinary tumor boards is the
tissue awareness because his we have
traditionally used excessive IHC stains
to in tissue testing to obtain
histological diagnosis and so these
multiple disciplinary tumor boards that
most of us participate in help drive the
tissue stewardship conversation within
our system when clinical and ray
geologic features favor primary lung
cancer we limit ourselves to to IHC
stains and non-small cell lung cancer
this would assume that there's no
history of prior nonlin malignancy and
no strong evidence of squamous or
glandular of differentiation we use
ttf-1 as an ad no carcinoma marker and
we use p63 or in most cases p40 as a
marker for squamous cell carcinoma so
our process is really attempting to
limit unnecessary stains to leave
sufficient tissue available for all
needed biomarker testing for patient
care I'll say just one slide about
multidisciplinary tumor boards because I
think both in academic and the community
setting that should be the number-one
objective that we are trying to achieve
because many studies have shown how they
increase patient care and have a wide
impact both by allowing physician and
provider communication and using
efficiently system resources and
personnel one issue we have is that it's
very challenging to find a meeting time
that works well for all specialties in
our system when you found that either 7
a.m. or noon conferences work very well
and since we are a geographically
diverse system we have live web based
and calling options due to a significant
infrastructure investment our system is
made everyone that participates knows
that this takes quite a long amount of
time to prepare these cases but it's a
wonderful collegial environment and the
benefits really do outweigh the increase
time commitment to prepare materials for
multidisciplinary tumor boards so if you
do not participate in MDT boards I'll
highly encourage you to help set them up
in your institution
now we've talked a little bit about
tumor heterogeneity so let's talk about
oncogene and mutational heterogeneity
that you see for driver mutations within
lung cancer we've talked about alch EGFR
and Ross one but we also have ret b-raf
wrasse met and pik3ca so after treatment
in addition to the oncogene mutational
heterogeneity that we see in
non-small-cell lung cancer we can also
have heterogeneity and resistance
mutations if we look at the evolution of
molecular pathology knowledge for
non-small cell lung cancer over the last
25 years our first biomarker was
histology being able to differentiate an
adenocarcinoma from a squamous cell
carcinoma we initially found that
patients with non-small cell lung cancer
had chaos mutations and egfr mutations
in 2009 we started talking about drug
sensitivity mutations in egfr both the
primary drug resistance and acquired
drug resistance in today's time we know
that it takes at least profiling of 18
genes to fully characterize a non
small-cell lung cancer so the smallest
biopsy with the widest number of
biomarkers that we need to assay in
today's molecular laboratories the quest
for knowledge has really led us to
next-generation sequencing multigene
pan-cancer panels are widely used for
biomarker screening they are used for
use very useful for initial biomarker
screening but are considered off-label
for prescribing companion diagnostic
therapeutics many of the panels have
very limited clinical information for
most of the panel targets and mutations
and in the community setting usually
next-generation sequencing is sent out
although it may be performed in house in
academic or large community settings
many oncologists have data anxiety due
to the large number of mutations and a
large amount of information bio
information they get back from a
next-generation sequencing panel
accurate informatics are required the
therapeutic information reports needs to
be constantly updated which can really
be challenging for a law
h next generation sequencing panel but
really one of the nice things about
next-generation sequencing panels is it
helps us drive clinical role clinical
trial enrollment opportunities for rare
targets we still think that single gene
companion diagnostics are small ng a
small next-generation sequencing panels
are much more appropriate for therapy
selection so we use NGS screening on the
front end and then we back it up with a
fda cleared companion diagnostic for
therapeutic selection in most instances
in my system let's talk a bit about
immunotherapy or pd one or PDL one as we
mentioned earlier than the associated
companion or complementary diagnostics
one of the newest companion diagnostics
is Prem realism AB which is a PDL 1
inhibitor is associated with the 22 c3
farm DX dako immunohistochemistry test
which detects PDL one expression
increased expression of PDL one is
usually associated with an increased
drug response for this immunotherapy PDL
one inhibitors enable t-cell targeting
of tumor cells and ramped up or increase
the immune response and they are
approved in non-small cell lung cancer
after progression on platinum doublet
chemotherapy or targeted therapy as I
mentioned earlier pin realism app has an
Associated companion diagnostic test so
both the therapeutic label which is at
the top of the slide and the test
package insert mentioned each other in
their intended uses and these can be
shown or seen on these slides in the red
box so it is very easy to understand the
relationship between the drug or
therapeutic and the biomarker based
tests as they require each other for
effective use now contrast this with no
volume AB which is a complementary
diagnostic if you look at the
prescribing indications for use for the
drug in the top half of the slide you
will see no mention of biomarker based
testing that is associated only in the
intended use for the
immunohistochemistry test at the bottom
of which you can see in the red box that
you see that the test mentions that it
can be used to select patients
nivolumab therapy so this leads to
several questions because our the 28 8
and 22 c3 IHC tests that are companion
diagnostic and complementary diagnostic
interchangeable or do you need to use a
specific amino histah chemistry test for
each therapeutic and if you have a
complementary diagnostic test that is
not required for safe and effective use
of a therapeutic compound will the
testing be be ordered now this is what
is occurring in the lung cancer space
but we know that both ppl 1 inhibitors
require no testing at all in for
melanoma there really is much buzz today
regarding immunotherapy d1 and PDL one
in many cancer types what we do know
about PDL one expression that is dynamic
and heterogeneous it's unclear what
level of expression is clinically
significant and we know that there are
multiple therapeutic compounds available
in the market also there are many IT
antibodies that have variable scoring
criteria variable instrumentation is
required we don't know what the sample
source is and if the testing has to be
performed off a fresh tissue or a biopsy
our progression performed at patient
progression or if archival tissue that
were used for patient diagnosis can be
used also the ability of ppl 12 acts as
a biomarker appears to differ
dramatically between different tumor
types and it can be particularly
problematic for the community setting
we're not all IHC antibodies may be
available and you may have to select
antibodies that our own event only
performed on your immunohistochemistry
systems that you have available so what
does the future hold for molecular
testing we have single gene test we have
next-generation sequencing we have
tissue based testing and we have plasma
based testing that is emerging it's
widely used in the European Union and
its emerging technique in the United
States I think for initial patient
profiling we will still be performing
that with tissue likely a large
next-generation sequencing panel and
then we will follow that up with tissue
or plasma based testing single gene
testing for real-time pcr to monitor a
patient for therapeutic use and also use
real-time pcr for tissue or probably
we in the not-too-distant future with
plasma to monitor the therapeutic
response and then when patients progress
maybe perform an additional larger panel
and go back and monitor patients with
single gene test with tissue or plasma
so I don't see next generation
sequencing really replacing single gene
biomarker testing I think they are
complementary techniques and for many
many years we will be using single gene
biomarker tests due to their sensitivity
and specificity along with
next-generation sequencing panels to
stratify patients for therapeutics both
using tissue and plasma based testing
now we do have a long journey ahead just
to give you an example of the challenges
that we talked about with sophisticated
biomarker testing I gave a lung cancer
education event in my home state North
Carolina early last year and there was
actually cigarette vending machine in
the back of the room where I was giving
the lung cancer education story so we
have many lifestyle and environmental
choices that patients need to make to
help us reduce the risk and rate of lung
cancer as well because we really do not
see the huge benefit of these wonderful
targeted therapeutics if people are not
making appropriate lifestyle choices so
no matter how sophisticated we are in
medicine and molecular diagnostics we
still need patience to make healthy
choices as well so to summarize where we
are with the presentation I think while
there are many challenges to implement
biomarker testing as it is the standard
of care for non-small cell lung cancer
both in the academic and community
settings please remember that biomarker
testing methodology selection is
critical choosing companion diagnostic
tests in their improved performance
versus laboratory developed test the
techniques that are widely used with
real-time pcr immunohistochemistry fish
and next-generation sequencing and then
also something that is very important
that I cannot emphasize enough is the
importance of multidisciplinary tumor
boards in helping provider communication
between the many specialties that are
involved in caring for and diagnosing
lung cancer patients it's also I think
the
take home messages that targeted therapy
in the era that we are both for lung
cancer for colorectal cancer for
melanoma and many other tumor types is
wonderful targeted therapy really is
improving the patient experience and
improving patient outcomes and I thank
you very much for your attention and at
this time I think we'll move into our
question-and-answer session thank you
dr. longshore for that informative
presentation now it's time for Question
and Answer if you have a question you'd
like to ask dr. longshore please do so
now just click on the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window type your question into the box
that appears on your screen and click on
the send button will answer as many of
your questions as we have time for so
with that let's get started our first
question dr. longshore do you feel that
physicians are proficient in selecting
the correct test panels and how r that
educated in the fast-changing field oh
that's that's a great question because
you definitely in the oncology setting
see two two types of oncologist you see
those who are very particular about
making sure that their patients are
tested with a particular type of test
and you see other oncologists who
reliable and pathology and the molecular
lab its use the best platforms and best
methodologies to be used for their
testing I do think that it's it's
something that requires some education
that we do a lot of that at our
multidisciplinary tumor boards as well
because as a molecular pathology
specialist or a pathologist we certainly
have a day-to-day grasp of the testing
environment and testing landscape so I
think that's a decision that really
needs to be made based upon the type of
materials you have available from your
box ii collection with pathology and
oncology working hand in hand because
there are some very powerful tests that
have some drawbacks as well and making
informed testing decisions are very
important ok our next question we know
that heterogeneity of tumor tissue
itself is a problem do you have any
suggestions for how how you can maximize
the the testing process so that you can
get a better representation of the
mutations that are reflective of the
whole tumor yeah that's that's another
great question tumor heterogeneity
something that we that we all deal with
one thing that we try to do on the
tissue side with navigational
bronchoscopy is to do multiple
navigational approaches during the
biopsy process so if we approach a tumor
from multiple angles our multiple
navigational approaches we're actually
by seeing different areas of the tumor
which can help cut down on tumor
heterogeneity because then those cores
are going to be placed into the same
plot into the same plane when we put
them on the microtome to use them for
biomarker based testing the other
exciting future use may be for the so
called liquid biopsy or plasma based
testing because for patients whose
tumors shed DNA we do know that they
don't just shed from one area but shed
from the entire tumor and liquid
biopsies although at present have
slightly decreased sensitivity vs tissue
based testing seem to do a much better
job of managing tissue heterogeneity and
give us a much more of a much broader
picture of what's going on the overall
tumor versus the single four or five
microns section that we maybe have we
may have selected for tissue based
testing great our next question do you
feel that the tissue requirement for the
companion diagnostics the fact that they
do actually require biopsy tissue do you
feel like that is providing any harm to
the patients is a limiting their
treatment availability just thoughts on
getting tissue right I think you know
getting tissue seems to be in my
experience getting sufficient tissue is
less of a problem now than it was five
years ago when kind of the Golden Age of
companion diagnostic started I think
most of the modern companion diagnostics
have a very minimal tissue input it may
be slightly greater than what the claims
are for some of the next generation
sequencing panels but what my lab and
others have found is we are getting
clonal selection of and not a very good
representation of the tumor when we use
the minimum amount of tissue for a
next-generation sequencing panel so
we found that the sensitivity offered by
own label companion diagnostic testing
is better than what we can get with a
next-generation sequencing panel for
egfr reallys all I can speak for because
that that's all we have looked at but
certainly is an issue it's not a big
problem getting sufficient DNA from a
small biopsy if you use an appropriate
isolation method to perform companion
diagnostic testing so from a normal fine
needle aspirate or a core needle biopsy
we always have sufficient material to be
able to form EGFR alch ross and any
other downstream tests we need in
addition to an NGS panel if it is
indicated great question that another
question about what happens to the
mutations in these lung cancer patients
when they're on treatment and then
following treatment what do we see as a
pattern for that evolution that that's a
good question we don't have a lot of
information since we don't see really
test patients outside of a clinical
trial but normally what we see is due to
selective pressure we need GFR with exon
19 deletions and the l85 8r mutations is
we tend to see them decrease during
therapeutic and emergence of resistance
mutations what remains to be seen is
when you take a patient off of a
targeted therapeutic for a period of
time and then reach Allen JH them with
the same targeted therapeutic for an
exon 19 deletion or an l eight 858 our
mutation they do seem in many cases to
respond again so it's not a single use
of a targeted therapeutic they can often
be reach Allen's with the same
therapeutic after they've developed
resistance and perhaps being been
treated with a targeted therapeutic that
is specific for the resistant sub
resistance mutations so it is a kind of
a cat and mouse game that you have to
play one thing that is I think
particularly exciting that we're
starting to see in clinical trials is a
combination therapy or multiple
therapeutics being directed at a
particular mutation and its rescue
pathway may be the most common
resistance
mutation pathway and I think targeted
therapies are something moulton
combination targeted therapies or
something we're going to see a lot more
off over the next few years because it
will really give us a improve duration
of response if you were targeting both
the driver mutation and its primary
resistance mechanism at the same time do
you think that as technologies evolve
that we will start to look at serial
monitoring for these patients as a
viable alternative to get ahead of
treating them and keeping them healthy
right and another great question I think
one of the drawbacks in doing serial
monitoring of patients with tissue is
that it's an invasive process every time
a patient has a navigational
bronchoscopy or a CT guided biopsy
performed that's one of the exciting
things about the emerging field of
liquid biopsies and plasma based testing
because we we can then start performing
serial testing perhaps even looking at
the at the load of mutation present in a
patient's bloodstream if their tumor is
shedding DNA and then probably determine
the development of a resistance mutation
we will see that before we can see it in
any tissue biopsy so I think that really
is going to be what we're doing the
other thing that's nice about that is
while ct-guided biopsy zin navigational
bronchoscopy usually are performed in
your larger community settings or in
your academic higher-tier medical
centers you don't see a lot of that in
the community setting or a patient may
have to travel a long distance to have a
biopsy I say everybody has a great
phlebotomist so I think the availability
of the liquid biopsy and plasma based
testing is really going to open up
serial monitoring and more testing in
the community setting because this can
be performed with a simple blood draw
rather than having to travel in many
instances to have a targeted biopsy by a
pulmonologist or a radiologist performed
so a question about if you if there is a
need to do a test and the lab did not
have the capability to perform that test
themselves in house what are some of the
questions that they can ask or some of
the data that they can look at to ensure
that the lab
they're looking to send their samples to
your as an accurate quality lab any
thoughts on that right that's a good
question is how do you how do you vet a
lab so to speak that you are sending out
testing too many of the lads the large
commercial reference labs are happy to
share their QA QC processes or tell you
how they validated a test which can be
exhaustive many of them have published
their data I would always shy away from
a lab that is hesitant to share what
tests they perform what method they use
or tell you how they validated a test I
think you know you want to look for a
lab that's not really hiding anything
you know a lab should be an open shop to
tell you how they perform a testing and
how they validate testing because if
you're comfortable with your methods I
don't think anyone is uncomfortable with
telling people about those processes and
it can be quite challenging because
there is a lot of direct marketing of
testing to mycologist and in many
instances many of these companies are
avoiding the pathology loop altogether
and directly marking to the oncologist
so it can be very challenging for a
provider to determine what is a good
accurate method to be used for their
patients versus what is a slick
marketing brochure that looks good but
may not be the best type of testing for
your patience so certainly a great
question okay I think we have time
probably for one or two more questions
so if you'd like to submit questions
please use your Q&A button there's one
here for you do you have any thoughts on
recommending app tomers as an
alternative to antibodies this really
something that is far out of my area
especially so I'm not going to attempt
to show my ignorance about app tumors
and antibody testing by attempting to
answer it but I'm sure there's somebody
out there much better qualified than I
am I'm much more of a DNA driven person
than an antibody driven question so I'm
sorry for not being being able to answer
that for you
okay this time we don't have any more
questions so I would once again like to
thank dr. longshore for his wonderful
presentation and do you have any final
comments before we conclude no I just
thanks everybody for your participation
today and I hope you have found the the
comments useful thank you again to lab
roots and to roche diagnostics for
supporting this and many thanks to karen
for moderating the session today okay
reminder for listeners out there this is
an educational webinar and thus offers
free continuing education credits so
once we conclude the webinar please
click on the c/e button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process to obtain your
credits before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through October 7th of this year you
will receive an email from lab roots
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's event thank
you so much for joining us we hope to
see you again soon and that concludes
our presentation for today